えこんにちは
今日はここ日本橋ですけれども
日本は先進国と言われています
しかし
貧困
これは
途上国だけの問題ではなくて
先進国でも問題になっ
今日本では貧困と格差が広がっている
こういうこの数字6人に1人約2000万人
これは日本の
貧困ライン以下で生活をしている人たちの数です
こういう話をすると峡谷は日本橋ですけれども
大手町とかまでの家でこういう話をすると
日本に貧困であるんですかと聞かれ
他方
生活に困っている人たちに寄り添って活動している npo の人たち
お話をすると
日本に貧困はうっていうことを知らない人なんているんですか
後期会
このギャップが極めて大きいですね
これが日本の貧困を
めぐ
調教です
実際
日本の政府も
2009年までは日本に貧困がないと言ってました
実際にはあったんですけれどもないといっ
それが
2009年に
厚生労働省の国民生活基礎調査
いうので
公式に貧困ラインを引いてここで以下で生活している人は健康
いうことを
発表しました
日本の貧困の特徴は
ひとり親家庭
中でも
シングルマザーのお母さん
の過半数が金庫んだということなんです
美味しいの先進国30号韓国
こんな国は日本だけなんですね
一億総中流位は出てたこの日本
今はそうではなくなっています
現代の日本では
失職職を失ったり病気や怪我い
したり
あるいは配偶者と離別をしたり士別をしたり
あるいは介護の必要が元さんおかあさんの買い物必要が出てきたという時に
ほとんどの人にとって
誰でも貧困に陥るリスクがある
こういう社会に我々ません
近郊は決して他人事ではなくて明日は我が身の問題
いうふうに思います
しかし位
シグマ山お母さんたち生活に困っているシングルマザーのお母さんたちを見て
私たちは
ああ
彼女たちはこれまで努力が足りなかったんだ
あるいは能力はなかったんだ
あるいは
[音楽]
うんがわかったじゃないかと
こういう自己責任とか
日号自得ということで
断定してないでしょうか
私たちはこの問題は
個人の問題ではなくて
社会の問題として問い合わせ買わなきゃいけないんじゃないかという風に考えています
というのは
親の年収が高ければ高いほど
その子さんが高等教育を受ける割合
これは大きい如実に
違うんですね
これは客観的なデータとして存在する
それで6割以上の中卒の人
4割以上の
高卒の人は
にしかなれない
非正規になると
これは男女を問わずですけれども
正規の職員正規の社員の
1/3の年収しかない
非正規の
家庭で育った
お子さんはなかなか教育試験に回らないので
この貧困が連鎖を裾
貧困が固定化数社会構造がある
この田さを足し切らなきゃいけない
私は金融には
貧困を解決する力があると信じています
金融というのは本剤
本当に必要な
お金が必要な人に
必要なものが回る
これが
2000年の人類の英知のはずなんです
ところが現実にはそうなってない
そこで
マイクロファイナンスという知恵が
あくまでたん
皆さんもご存じだと思いますけれどもパンガーディッシュの
グラミン銀行
まあまあでブースターんが
創設したものですけれども
貧困削減したとマークの金融でそれで2006年にノーベル平和賞を受賞された
当時このマイクロファイナンスっていうのはアジアとかアフリカとか
開発途上国のものだと思われていました
しかし
今アメリカでもフランスでも
ドイツでもオランダでもノルウェーでもエンバーグでも
うマイクロファイナンス機関が
ができている
日本にも必要とされて
それで我々は
グラミン銀行の日本盤が3日本というのを
この9月13日に設立をして事業回使用しています
これまで金融ではカバーされなかった
働くよく
だけども今ちょっとお金に困っている
あるいは今の生活をステップアップさせていきたい
前向きにしていきたいという若い人たちワーキングプアの若い子達
こういう人たちに
企業とか
人にはとは就労だとかその為の準備のための資金を融資をするマイクロファイナンス
期間です
ご覧のように
グラミン銀行
いうのは
通常の銀行とは真逆のことをやっています
例えば
お金持ちにはお金貸さないで
お金のない人に関数
それから
タンポンと
保証とかは
ておりません
銀行にお金をは仮に行くときには銀行に作3章でをつくってこれで査定を簡単に無効化
の銀行委に査定をしてもらう
平見銀行は銀行員が
買い手の
人のところに行って来たり他の人の家とかコミュニティとか近くの便利のいいところに
あってくる
グラミン銀行はプラ3日本
は基本的にこのグラミン銀行と同じビジネスモデルで
日本で事業を始めようと思っています
第15支店はこの日本橋国家程近いところに
9月から
オフィスをかまえて
治療を始めています
まあ
恨みアメリカとかグラミン
バンクはてしたグラミー事か
同じモデルでやりますけれども日本には日本の実態に合ったように少しだけ
修正をしてやろうと思っていますけれども基本的にこの犬さんのいうソーシャル
ビジネス7原則
聞いたことがある方もいらっしゃると思いますけれどもこれに基づいて設立をして自己
事業を上をすると
この原則7つありますけれどもこの原則の医師から
1利益の最大化ではなくて社会のも社会問題の解決こそが目的であること
そうは言ってもう原則に
財務的に持続可能じゃなきゃいけないこれはよく日本でもゆる社会起業とかソーシャル
ビジネスの鉄則です
この437原則の特徴的なことは3番目の原則
投資家は100を投資したらそれでビジネスをした結果120とか30になったらその
100という元本は戻ってくるけれども
この23中は配当という形では金銭的な形では投資家に
1円もものがないじゃあどうするかって言うと俺は今やってるソーシャルビジネスを
拡大したり改善したりするためですか
投資家は100という元本以外の配当5は非金銭的なギターんとして人の人のために
なった社会のためになった困ってる人を助けたという充足感を得るこういう原則です
それからもう一つ特徴的なのはこの原則の得です
スタッフは
同じことをやってるんであれば同じことをやっている企業の
給料と標準ぐらいの標準の旧よりもたくさんほら教授ん以上の給与をもらう
この原則さんと原則底合わせて考えるとですね
この乳酸の u 7原則は
今まで軸足を株主においてたものを少しだけ
スタッフの側に社員の側に移すという国家のある原則
だっ
から原則なら
ウェストウイットリージョイ
楽しみながらワクワク者がやろうよ
これがのグラミン銀行グラミー日本の
モットーです
じゃ
なんで
日本で恨みにを設立しようと思ったのか
まず私のパーソナルな原体験がありまして
私は福島あの小さな酒屋の息子です
長男なので足の親父は
私にその家業の酒屋を継がせたいと思っていました
まあですが私はと高校卒業したと東京に出てきてしまったので
親父の一番下の弟こっから言うとおじさんですけれども
おいさんが影をついてくれた
1990年代2000年代
競争至上主義
弱肉強食
新自由主義
こういう風潮が
普通だった時代がありました
その時に大店法ができお子さんは
廃業に追い込まれる
家屋敷も担保にと取られ
腕がもう少し
うまくやれば良かったようなましたけどこう言って
行方不明になってしまいました
僕はその時の社会の対応を見てなんて冷たい社会なんだろう
そ強く思いました
自分が年をとったときにはこんな社会には絶対に住みたくない
強く思いました
た4
私は大蔵省で
今の厚生労働省の予算査定の仕事をしたり
金融行政の仕事をしたり
oda の担当課長という仕事をしたいしてました
その
プライベートな
出来事と
いままでやってた多くや商法でやってた仕事の交わったところにマイクロファイナン
スっていうのがあったんです
2017年の
[音楽]
ゆうさんが
日本に来られてこの資格の大手町でセミナーを開かれる
貧困削減と日本の役割というテーマで
そう的私はオーディエンスの一人としてそのセミナーに行ったんですが
貧困問題というのは
世界でも日本でも全く解決してないんだ
っていうことを改めてその時わかりました
それでマイクロファイナンスということも分かりました
それマイクロファイナンスを勉強すれば勉強するほど
これは深くてとっても広い概念だということも分かりました
それで
今までの
自分の大蔵省での行政経験っていうのは
マイクロファイナンスを
やるためにあったんじゃないかとさえ
ようになって
2018年の3月に
タッカーのグラミン銀行の本部に
犬さんを
訪ねて行きました
飲茶日本でもマイクロファイナンスでできるでしょうか
いきました
犬さんは
アメリカやフランスでも行っている日本でも必ずやできる
励ましてくれました
それから10年
実際日本でグラミン音グラミン銀行というものを立ち上げようとする時に
なかなか
心配で不安で夜も眠れない日が続きました日本で本当にマイクロファイナンスで出来る
んだろうか
日本で
5人一組のグループを組んで
カリタくれる人なんて言うんだろう
小学の
経理牛で
実際に事業っていうのはさせアプリになるんだろう
不安で夜が眠れませんでした
それで
恨みアメリカ
2008年に始まりましたがニューヨークの恨みアメリカにインターンのような形で
入らせてもらって実際どうやってんだろう
みました
しかし
自分が
お金を貸すと
いうことに
心がざわつく自分がいた
これではだめだ
これでは自分は舞妓とファーナスや資格がない
できない
それで
こっちの岸から向こうの岸におっ
いうことで
四国の現像方法に行ったりしなきゃいけないんじゃないかなぁ
思ったりしていました
その時に
転機が訪れました2017年の2月21日
new さんにこの事を指数と
ゆうさんには会うたびに
勇気と希望をもらえる人なんですが私があの今までの人生独自を超えましたけれども
一番尊敬する人です
この時も
勇気と希望をもらって
この悪臭をした時からこれが天気になって私の眠れないようでは
質が変わりました
それまでは
不安で眠れなかっ
そのこの後この握手の後は明日は何1年何やろう
ワクワクしようとが眠じゃなくなったんです
それでこの握手の半年後
2017年の8月に
一般社団法人グラミー日本準備飛行というものを発車
なスマ仲間たちが集まってくれました弁護士会計士さん
普通の企業で働いている人たち金融機関で当たれている浸し
コンサルタントの人たちたくさんの仲間が集まってくれ
ある女性はこの女性は金融機関で働いていた女性ですけれども
本当に会いたいことに人生で初めて出会ってきます
もしかしたらこれが人生で
最後になるかもしれない
持ってくだ目に参加したい
なんで燃やしてほしい何でも屋分
いま彼女は恨み日本の中核メンバーです
もう1人
この男性は
大手コンサル会社の
幹部候補でした
高級をとっ
をやめて
覚悟を決めて態度をたっ
恨みにすべてをコミットしたい
画面日本の成功を確信して
今ポテグラミンで行っている
自分のこの仕事っていうのは健食だと思っている
一緒にやろうということで彼は今グラミー日本を担ってくれています
恨み日本が目指し社会
我々の自然体切っていうのは7つありますけれどもその一丁目一番地は品行のない
誰もは生き生きと生きられる社会を作っ
です
順風満帆にいくとは思っていません
からもや周りたにある
だけど4[ __ ]は
この一点にコミットして
何があっても逃げない
私たちはこの覚悟を決めて
new さんは言います
目標が難しくて見え難しく難しく見えれば見えるほどその仕事はワクワクしたものに
なっ
私もまったく同感です
faster のファーと検査これはアフリカの言葉です
早く行きたければ
一人で
遠くまで行きたければみんなで一緒に
肌の屈強な人とカイリーとは目標に多数
達いくために1人でポートスだからアフリカの自然は厳しい
サハラ砂漠の日 riri で死んじゃったりあるいはじゃぁ後でではに加えて死ん
じゃったんです
だけど自分側に加えて死んでも
自分の志を持っている同じ仲間がその目的地にたしたすればそれでいい
それがアフリカ人の知恵なんですねこれはアフリカのことわざです
faster 道 part 芸さ
グラミー日本も
目指す社会目指す理念っていうのはあっ
かなり遠くて大きいところが
だから私たちは皆で一緒に行っ
近郊のない
誰もが生き生きといけない社会をつくるために
どうか皆さんも一緒に歩んで頂けないでしょうか
お力を貸してくださいありがとうございました
[拍手]